how do you guys feel about the live
action
uh remix i know you know obviously
beauty and the beast has been done i
know um
josh gad is working on the hunchback uh
right now and there's been talk about
atlantis
live action um yeah um um you know it's
funny i
i sort of have mixed feelings about
about about the live-action remakes on
the one hand
you know it's it's great to have been
involved in
in in movies that have had you know so
much
so much longevity and have created so
much affection
uh uh before them in the audience uh
that they'd be excited to see you know a
new adaptation of the movie
but sometimes i you know i found myself
saying well just
go watch the old one it's still watching
it
you want to see it again watch the
animated one i know i know
i mean my my like completely objective
and non-varnished opinion
is that the animated ones are better
anyway you know to every single one of
them
but that's just me it's not just you
you guys both have credits on on on the
live action
beauty and the beast but so many other
of the story artists and all these
people that contributed
don't have anything and i'm assuming
don't have any kind of like financial
oh god no you know i certainly didn't
get a written
from the live action yeah there was
there was no financial to it and
and the fact that we got credit was a
surprise to me
yeah me too thanks you know i went to
the um
i appreciate it i got i got uh invited
to the uh to the premiere at the el
capitan which was a surprise
i know don hahn pulled strings to make
that happen
and was there sitting in the audience
with my girlfriend and the credits went
by and was like
holy crap there i am
now it was you know
[Laughter]
yeah yeah